we are back here with ecstasy and Tyler
one xkc just beat tyler1 2-0 we got them
here was this the most important match
of pogchamp so far
sorry was there a question for me
oh dude what the question was but let me
say
ing I should have been given at least 15
minutes of extra time to play I would
have smoked them the first round he was
panicking he's 700 rating above me and I
had him shook move for move and wasn't
even close her second game wasn't wasn't
competitive that was my bad I still did
some trolling his garbage at chess it
needs to uninstall forever
he made me reschedule the last last week
and then he's 30 minutes now late now
X could see your trash
holy is it like a time bank I had a
talking pillow now and I can talk now
right
yeah I said it early when I was talking
I'm signing the broadcast I said it he's
he was cheating it I get it I won I
Michaela's on the room and he's she's
getting him the [__] moves I could
tell I I could tell the way he's moving
Michaela was giving him the moves it's
obvious it's yeah
he was playing web of his rating he was
playing an average of like 900 1.1 K
average as of 200. actually cheating it
is absolutely right I played above my
level because when the pressure's on
Prime and time again I perform I play up
to my opponent even at games I'm not
even the best at and unfortunately you
played down cheer opponent he's gonna
pip squeak and squatty in real life xqc
you're lucky this is all you have is is
this little video game career I play
this for fun while I'm working actual
labor jobs in real life and I still
invested you almost
you play League of Legends what is he
talking about
I work on pool labor
starters and repair pools actually
okay
third podcast I'll let you talk oh well
I have a landscaping job and an office
job and I stream it and I play chess I'd
imagine probably yeah an hour late to
that too and in the real world xqc
that's not acceptable and hopefully in
the chess.com world that's not
acceptable for the quarters either but
you show up an hour late for that maybe
he'll face some punishment
one point for time for this one but
listen it you didn't understand that
there's a law behind this again
this small person big-headed muscle head
is still molding it because I cheated
against him in twitch Rivals and I got
banned I got banned for a week for it
and I couldn't stream it and he wanted
to take revenge it he called Michaela to
cheat against me to get his revenge and
even would make it 2V1 I beat them two V
one two brains can you get to mine and
he got me tell her
yeah I have about 15 comments Number One
X you see you they have to bring in IRL
stuff about that because look at you
your pale you look like a ghost bro that
can't be healthy you weigh 75 pounds
again remember me snapping the pin I
could snap you bro first of all you
don't want to bring iron all of this
because I beat you and everything in
that secondly stop accusing me of
cheating it's just a compliment because
I wasn't okay and then thirdly about the
cheating comment with you cheating yes
hello he's admitted to cheating in a
previous tournament hello
yes you beat me this time you won't by
the way you will not go to semis you are
terrible by the way no no character
aside you are actually terrible it is
right is right yeah
I will I did put terrible okay but when
your opponent is way way way oh it's
more than enough
your thoughts bro you struggle to get
squeaks and that dude sucks
against him
oh okay well squeaks is really really
really really bad you're not wrong
um I mean the guy was well he was he was
wearing a wig that's enough about him he
was wearing a wig that's true
that is insane
secure from the start that's true that's
true
let me get this way we could both play a
year of Chess you wouldn't beat me I we
yeah I lifted if I lifted for a year I
would beat your PB I said it excuse me
450 pounds say the hell out of 450
pounds bro I squat 600 pounds put the
arms away you have nothing to show
are we gonna allow him to embarrass
production like this dude you're not
serious
yes
for sure have you not I heard that
you're getting GM pointers by that
hikiru guy for that guy's name is and he
was Bond reviewing me and then leaking
it to you probably true actually and
even playing this is your like second
POG Champs right or your third I don't
know how many of these have there been I
don't keep track this is my first one
yeah um yeah Iceland dude I've already
actually I was watching
um she gave up on you entirely
he he actually retired yeah but he
actually retired he hasn't seen in a
long time and then see why she plays
my potential while playing and he was
like oh I'll never match this guy and he
retired I made him quit chess congrats
I'm a freak
well you know it's lovely to see you
guys really passionate about the game
and Pog Champs and you know with Tyler
there's plenty of grand amasters who
could coach this was a really lovely
professional interview which um
for a second give me your honest opinion
I played impressive chess compared to
before you did
um
by the way
no I I yep we were gonna say at the end
of the day no matter what's going on
with who can Flex harder who has bigger
muscles let's not forget that the people
United for chess today and Tyler you
played a great game the truth is you're
200 rated and xqc wasn't enough
games and at least 1 000 rating I am not
200 right thank you I'm just saying what
the number underrated for sure that's
what I was trying to I didn't finish my
sentence I was gonna say you played much
above your level and today you Rose to
the ranks and we are very excited
because both of you guys are going to be
making it to the championship bracket
which means you may battle again and now
there's gonna be even more more insane
chess competition
um so we'll really we really love how
much you guys love chess and you know
how competitive you are and Tyler it was
nice to see you do some studying it was
good to see the cow today we're happy to
help with chess lessons Hikaru has
retired so um you know you'll have to
settle first Grand Master
big Tonka 200. I'll see you on the next
game brother
he's not 200.
who are you guys most excited to play in
the championship bracket
both of you I'm excited who was it was
he playing it
yeah you guys are both in the
championship
we both go talk to the bracket all right
how they work yeah you guys you're yeah
you both made it this game was just for
pride and stuff you're in the same city
okay I don't think Genie has ever seen a
chessboard before and squeaks was busy
playing Connect Four in the middle of
the game how is it fair that he gets a
free passes in the bracket what would it
be Priceless he's 200 and he played very
well so I think it's very well dessert
um I don't know anybody on this list
unfortunately so I don't know well looks
like you guys are each other's greatest
enemies you don't know sapnap he plays
Minecraft blood is called the German xqc
and Frank was awesome but he's not
really well known outside of the chess
Community
I played I know snap that but played
league with them once
you guys are kind of you know it's an
identity crisis if you guys play each
other
you can be a golden egg okay but I'm the
Golden Goose okay there's multiple
versions of excuses I get from all other
languages it doesn't matter I am better
how many copies of Taiwan is there none
nobody because
erupt is pretty close
okay we're we're related by blood only
relax
ha
okay final question do you think that
you will face each other in the live
finals in LA
if he makes it to the finals so so uh
you guys be in the same room to be
honest I'm flying from Sweden challenge
to see that I've promised that I will do
it
I'm not scared I'm not scared to one
okay I I would do chess boxing against
them even though even though
five second round and I'm not even
talking about the boxing portion you'd
lose it five seconds on the chest
portion
my sister weighs more than you actually
see and she's nine
okay but that doesn't change it's like
you have a T-Rex Builder
T-Rex Andy how does it work guys guys
he's flexing for the camera we all know
this it's fine do we have to win the
whole thing on each side of uh uh how
many people go to La exactly only the
two finalists you guys would both have
to be top in your group to meet yeah and
the constellation finalists so four
people in total
I hope he makes it I actually hope he
makes it uh you know I didn't really
want to go back to LA because I just
left L.A I escaped Ellie and I have to
go back now for your tournament
it is what it is
I'm just kidding I I'll win the whole
tournament
okay
in the same as online chess if you
thought you had it hard I will [__] you
up in real life
xqc now you're talking crazy now
watch it watch yourself watch it I'll
see Atlanta
well this is I think the match-up that
we all need to see to settle this once
and for all Tyler if you want to get
coached to Prodigy they will do it same
for ux but we know you would like to do
your own type of studying but Tyler I
want to see you guys go face to face I
think this is the chat match that chat
wants to see most yeah I mean I'm
playing the cow Tyler keep on playing
the counter yeah
I I messed it up but you were shook
a week in advance we are still looking
for it
okay I was eating chicken right there
and I thought about you and the game of
chess and I fell asleep it doesn't count
I took a small impromptu nap okay I was
dreaming about you
can't wait to see a dollar
okay yeah as you see why you keep saying
that okay can we move on now he's being
weird
yep all right ladies and gentlemen thank
you guys for joining us this was a
really lovely interview we're looking
forward to more chess and
um let's let's go to the standings
yeah thank you so much let's check out
it was a pleasure guys thanks so much